so this is non imperative network
programming sorry for the late start
I'm Mindy Preston I'm gonna start off
with a couple of disclaimers views
expressed are my own they're not anyone
else's no one no one bribed me enough to
come up and give an give their opinion
instead of mine and also I'm new to
functional programming there are
definitely people in this room who have
better ideas about this topic than I've
seen yet and I really want to hear them
that's part of the reason I wanted to do
this talk so I saved a lot of time for
questions at the end and I really hope
to hear some great great questions and
yes even statements I'm going there so
I'm just a quick outline of what I'm
going to talk about I'm going to throw
out some definitions I'm going to talk
about network interfaces as we sort of
traditionally learn them in this kind of
imperative style I'm going to talk about
interfaces as module types in no camel
I'm gonna talk about kind of a grab bag
of nice things to have and then I have
some time for questions after that so
first off what I mean when I say non
imperative I run in circles that kind of
throw the term declarative around a lot
but this is really what I'm trying to
get at is interfaces and code that
fulfill these properties they're
independent they're stateless and
they're deterministic we're going to
examine some approaches that are more
declarative than the network programming
paradigms that we traditionally teach in
systems classes but we're not going to
get all the way to a working interface
that unambiguously fulfills all of those
criteria so sorry if that's what you're
here for you can there's no tables to
table flip but you could probably like
flip a chair and run out
and what I mean when I say network
programming is the part of your code
that is concerned with sending messages
to and receiving from programs running
on other computers on the other end of
like greater than one Network link I'm
talking about the layers of abstraction
that we use to send messages between
computers over potentially lossy Network
links most of the time when we're doing
application programming we don't get to
think about like the full depth of the
stack we often say full stack and we
mean like a client to a server on layer
8 we have we have this we have this kind
of this level of abstraction presented
to us because the operating system
represents the network to us at this
layer of abstraction I should also
mention since I'm talking about messages
and links that I am not qualified to
talk about distributed systems so there
will be no photographs of anything on
fire during this talk I'm yeah sorry
sorry not sorry I guess so first off
network interfaces as we learn them or
as I learned them I guess I shouldn't
include you all in my personal past
experience so traditional operating
systems kind of want to handle like a
large part of networking for you the
applications access to the network is
mediated by the operating system and the
API that it chooses to present to the
application most of the time that's the
sockets API which which I've helpfully
labeled sockets in this nice little
diagram here so by accessing the sockets
API the application can request that
some stuff happens in the kernel to get
data out onto the network hardware and
on to the wire
there's not really another choice in
doing this in UNIX for the most part
like you can put stuff on top of it but
you can't get under it if you're doing
if you're doing network programming in a
UNIX environment at some point it's
probably going through there the sockets
API was originally designed for C but
like most languages have their own
interfaces for it and the interfaces
look really C like so let's have a
really quick look at the O camel
implementation of sockets and see
whether the functions that we see look
like they might be something that's
independent stateless or determine
stick so this is a little selection from
vo camel UNIX library which implements a
whole bunch of sockets stuff in addition
to a lot of variants like a bad file
descriptor
this Kinect isn't really very
declarative is it it does a side
effecting operation on the file
descriptor that we pass in so actually
let me back up and talk a little bit
about socket for a minute
so when we look at socket and what
socket is doing is taking some
description of three things that we're
asking for in our description of how
we're going to connect to the network
with this socket and then it's going to
give us back a file descriptor so we
need to tell it like what kind of
network do we want to connect to is it
ipv4 ipv6 is it some UNIX thing that's
pretending to be an IP network
do we want reliable transport or do we
want like faster but like not as
reliable transport do we need to
disambiguate that protocol because those
first two things weren't enough to tell
the thing what we wanted and once we've
gotten all that right we're gonna get
something back that looks like that
looks like a file on a file system that
we can hopefully do some interesting
stuff with and then connect is our
interface to actually turn that into
something that we can send packets to
and hopefully have them go down the wire
off to someone else you'll notice that
the return type of socket is unit sorry
the return type of Connect is unit
connect is side affecting and it is not
really possible to know if you just have
a file descriptor without any other
information whether it's currently set
up for you to send network stuff across
it like nunn of nunn of nunn of the
difference between like a socket that's
been set up and hasn't been set up is
represented in the type system at all in
this interface oh I should also mention
that um Connect is a really error-prone
function as well and this particular one
just will throw an exception and you'll
be sad because it happens very
frequently that you run connect and
you're like I'm gonna connect to my best
friend another server and the other
server goes I'm sleeping bro and this is
where you find out and your program goes
up and you're not a happy person so um
but it's also worth noting that this is
this is pretty much all of the
specification that we
of how we were going to interact with
the network over the course of this over
the course of the sockets lifetime we
can set a few more flags when we do
particular things but pretty much these
are our specs and they're really not
very precise this is just a rehash of
what's actually going on there but
there's a whole lot more possibilities
for the state that's represented by by
the operating systems choices about the
network that we really haven't had any
input into so this command is a sifts
ETL net on a UNIX machine it will give
you a list of all of the tunable network
parameters that you can access through
proc on my machine there are 688 which
is way more than three and even way more
than eight and even like like way more
than 10 like it's just it's a lot and
it's possible but you might even care
about some of them in your application
like for example this this particular
setting is the setting for the maximum
number of allowable waiting connections
in TCP and so you can imagine like
you're running a big webserver that
wants to take a lot of connections or
you're running a load balancer you care
about the value of this thing
unfortunately for you so if you're
running an application that cares about
this this application is always going to
care about that that's not going to stop
because you know the machine rebooted or
something happened to change the state
of the environment that your application
is running in you're the property that
you care about that is inherent to the
thing that you're trying to get done we
have a lot of DevOps tools for
attempting to make the values of
settings like this consistent over time
and over multiple machines they're all
essentially out-of-band updates which
take place like outside of the
application my application code it wants
that state and maybe it even wants to
set that state but it doesn't
necessarily have an in band way to
demand it and it might even not have a
nice interface for making sure that it's
set so implicit state I don't like it so
I'm gonna go on and talk a little bit
about interfaces as module types and how
I think we can build better interfaces
so what if we could choose or even make
our own abstractions for how to access
the network we could make whatever we
want to be implicit or implicit we could
have whatever knobs we wanted to tune be
exposed we could if we wanted to make
libraries that just return pictures of
cats all the time because that's really
all we want to do anyway so how can we
get to this beautiful future some of you
have been spoiled on this the answer is
you know kernels so in a traditional
operating system architecture you write
your code you compile it for an
operating system you run it on an
operating system that's probably running
on some virtualized hardware if you're
deploying it in production or in a cloud
in a unit kernel setup what you do is
you write your code you compile your
code and your code becomes an operating
system
you that you can then run on virtualized
hardware and this means that instead of
having the socket have instead of having
the traditional operating system
interface standing between your
application and what you can do with
network hardware you can potentially
have direct access to that through
whatever kind of libraries you want to
link in so you'll note um so this is
just sort of a sort of a diagram of the
things that you might have linked into a
unit kernel application that is running
that is running on a network so you have
your application code that you've run
and you're very proud of it and you want
it to go out into the world and succeed
and be happy you might have a library
that provides what we call the transport
layers so either reliable or unreliable
communication over a network and
datagrams you might have a network layer
library so that's that's I P V for ipv6
generally something that understands how
to handle whatever layer is below that
usually Ethernet or possibly Wi-Fi
although that would be a bit strange and
then something that knows how to talk to
whatever virtual network hardware you've
been provided by excuse me that you've
been provided by the environment in
which you're trying to get your unit
kernel up and running and then finally
all of that is going to be running over
a language runtime so
instead of running like memory unsafe
code in most in the unicorn environments
that I've that I have some experience in
you have the excellent benefit of having
a runtime that knows how to that knows
how to keep you from shooting yourself
in the foot when you are parsing input
off the wire from random people that you
don't know
so if we're going to talk about
replacing the monolithic structure of
sockets with something that is more
decomposable and something that we can
something that we can sort of interim
interact with a little bit more and
maybe involve ourselves a little bit
more in it's useful to impose maybe some
structure on what these on how these
libraries express themselves because if
we just say you can have a transport
layer library and you know I really want
my my application code to interact with
it in this way but you know the network
light I like whatever is beneath it it's
gonna have to interact with it in this
like different other way because I just
kind of felt differently that day you're
gonna have a bad time when you try to go
and compose all of these things so you
need to impose some kind of rules so the
unit kernel system that I have
experience in is called Mirage OS and
it's written in a camel and the way that
we deal with this problem in a camel is
all of these libraries are modules and
in no camel modules are allowed to have
module types so for example if I want to
make sure that I can easily swap my ipv4
library with an ipv6 library or my IP v4
module with an ipv6 module I'm sorry to
use those terms interchangeably but in
this case that's completely there's no
loss of meaning and doing that I can I
can then define a module I can define
module types for ipv4 and ipv6 so that I
have a stringent a stringent set of
rules for what ipv4 and ipv6 mean and do
in the context of this unicorn operating
system
I can then figure out the commonality
between these two things and make
another module type for just IP and I
can write interfaces for the link layer
and for the transport layer that speak
in terms of IP
so I just wanted to show you a few of
the module types that we have occurred
that are I work with a lot of the time
when I'm building you know kernels in
Rodge OS so if you're familiar with
doing with if you've done any kind of
stack programming before these are these
things are not super new to you so as I
mentioned we have module types for ipv4
and ipv6 and then a super type for ipv4
and ipv6
there are also some module types that
don't directly correspond to any
particular layer the nice thing because
these module types can be included in
one another you can build nice little
atoms for things that you want to be
represented in all sorts of things so
for example we have we have a module
type flow for connections between
endpoints which is useful for both which
is useful both in a network context of
you have a machine that wants to talk to
another machine over the network and
it's useful in the context of you have a
machine that wants to talk to another
machine over shared memory like for
example through the hypervisor the other
thing that I wanted to note is because I
did touch on this but I want to make it
really clear that because we're defining
these things in terms of module types we
can have separate implementations that
make different decisions that fulfill
these module types and then they're
interchangeable within our system so if
I decide that if I decide that I have a
really strong feeling about which TCP
congestion control algorithm I want to
use I can just swap whatever one I want
in there so does this actually look not
imperative when you look at it well
let's look at some more type signatures
before I make any decisions so this is
this is the type of the module type
signature for flow we have a type
parameter for doing for basically doing
side effecting operations that might
that we might want to yield for because
we're doing this is in a cooperative
multi-threading environment so you have
to be explicit about when you are when
you're yielding and when you when you
wish not to do that in your sequencing
we have a type float we have a type
that's basically a type for a big watch
of memory the fundamental building block
of doing stupid stuff if networks we
have an abstract
for our flow which is the thing that
we're implement these modules will be
implementing and speaking in terms of
and we have an error type because that's
just always kind of a good idea so we
have also some expected primitives we
can read our flows and we can like
either get some memory
yayyyy or discovered that the file that
someone else has closed the connection
booooo were sad something even worse
happened we're even sadder and the same
thing pretty much for right oh I should
probably be a little bit clearer about
this just in case there are just in case
there are somehow people who haven't
like ever program to no camel in the
room I don't know how that would ever
happen but so what's happening here with
this type signature is this is a
polymorph this is a tag it's basically
just a marker on some more data or
another type that says like I want to
address this as being okay it's very
reassuring another one that's AOF and
another one that's error and then this
type is one of those three things and
then the of something is the thing
that's attached to this okay tag is some
data that I might actually be able to do
something with same with your hopefully
so you might have noticed that there's
actually no way to create a flow in that
module like that's actually a pretty
complete representation of what's in the
flow module and there's a pretty obvious
thing missing everything is in terms of
a flow but you have no way to get one
it's one of the ways that you can get
one is in actually in a different module
type in an implementation of a different
module type so some implementation of
this tcp module type part of the
required signature for tcp things is
this value this function create a
connection with some tcp implementation
to some IP address and port and then if
everything went okay give me a flow that
i can use to communicate with it and if
things went badly give me an ER
so okay that's all that's all fun and
games how do we actually run a server
like how do we how do we compose this
and do something with it so there's
something else that a module type TCP
defines that you would probably expect
for something that wants to both send
and receive data we define a callback
which is just a function that goes from
flow to unit i/o so a side effecting
operation yeah sorry and we had defined
also an input function there's a little
bit of commenting down here which I
think might be a little bit hard to read
because of the color I apologize for
that but this input function just takes
a TCP implementation and then a function
from int to callback option which is
basically you would just write a
function that matches that matches on
the port number and says okay if this is
a port number on which I have some like
on which I want to do something returns
some that thing that I want to do if
it's a port number in which I'm not
interested return done so the the TC the
TCP implementation will then say if it
gets none it will just send a reset
packet and close it and not open a
connection if it has some callback that
it knows what to do with it will open
that it will initiate that connection
and the the callback will run with will
be in it will start running with the
value of the flow from the incoming data
connection so we can like define a
function and then just use it yeah so
this is a fairly trivial server which I
just basically just opens a service
takes takes up keeps reading a whole
bunch of data and then discards it if
you're a fan of old RFC's or blog posts
about old RFC's this is the I can't
remember the RFC number but it is the
standard service on port 9 so this is
this is a very succinctly limitation the
only thing that's missing is the I've
alighted report enclosed which I hope
doesn't confuse anyone but it does
exactly what it sounds like it just
complains about the error and then
closes the connection so what we have
defined here
is a recursive discard function that
will just keep whenever whenever it is
running it will continually try to read
this flow and the operation there is a
bind operator on the on the threading
library that we're using so basically
you can imagine that the it's basically
sequencing so we waited we waited until
we have figured we've found a way to
read the flow and we get a result we
figure out what the result was if it was
if something bad happened we report and
we close if if we got okay in some data
we don't care what our data is we're
just going to throw it away and then
we're gonna go back and do it all over
again
so this fulfills our type signature of a
flow to unit i/o so this is eligible to
be eventually shoved into our input our
input function so this this abstraction
down below with the s s dot listen and s
dot listen TCP v4 is a little bit of
syntactic sugar for how to set up those
input functions I'll show you the longer
way later but I'm just for brevity's
sake I wanted to show you the sort of
sugared version here
it's very frequently the case we've
discovered we've discovered in Mirage
that what you want is some
representation of all of the standard
things in a stack so the that we have a
we have a module type stack before that
provides all of those things bundled
together in yet another module this is
sort of a theme in Oh camel and Mirage
OS that if you have a problem and you
think a module like might kind of maybe
be a solution just go for that just do
it
so this is this is what it looks like
when you build the whole stack
explicitly so the basically what you do
is you are building you were building
your own module with some module
arguments in no camel we call this a
functor I'm sorry that we call it a
functor pasco people they didn't ask me
it has so it has some explicit inputs
which which are in the form of like
here's the this is the actual
implementation of the module and then :
in the module type so we have something
that represents a console we have
something that represents a network and
by network we mean like really low level
like a virtualized Hardware support
network we have something that
represents a clock and then something
that represents a way to get random
numbers so given our network we call we
call an Ethernet interface and we say
okay build me build me an Ethernet
module given what you know about this
network and given and okay now we have
Ethernet and we can send ethernet layer
messages and that's great but we want
more so since we're since we know that
we're going for ipv4 we need and we need
ARP sorry everybody ARP is a glue layer
between ipv4 and Ethernet and the less
you know about it the happier you are so
that you can be content that you know
enough about it right now that it needs
some stuff and it looks like it's
stateful and that's really sad
but given that once we have that we can
we can get our we can get an ipv4 module
which we could actually like use to send
messages that someone might care about
so that's great
UDP is also pretty simple just we can
just build it on top of of IP TCP is
quite a bit more complicated it has its
timers it needs to know like how long to
sleep for it needs to generate random
numbers it has all kinds of needs but we
have satisfied all of those needs right
here in this call and if and if we're in
the if we're in the situation where we
want to be dynamically assigned an IP
through the DHCP interface which runs
over UDP we also have to build this
slightly slightly hungry
slightly hungry module out of our
console a time implementation random and
UDP
so the reason that I'm talking about all
this is that I really love the
explicitness of the way that this is
built you can see at every single layer
like it's it's clear what you'll be
calling out to and because of the module
types it's clear what you're providing
so okay that's really cool I think
personally I don't know you feel about
it
but is it any more declarative like is
it actually any less imperative to build
your networks this way
so here's my argument for why I think it
is the layers of our stack as I said are
explicit and they're deliberate which
seems to me to give us some major
determinism points we can build our
applications in terms of pure functions
over inputs even if we have specific
api's that don't do that right now we
can build different we can build
different api's we have the power we
have we can define functions to process
this data without all of the implicit
external dependencies of our 688 things
that were in proc and to me that seems
like major plus independence points
so I'm going to talk a little bit now
about nice things to have so when we
have an interface to a network that is
presented as this fully virtualized bull
thing where we just have a module that
fulfills a module type there's no reason
that we can't actually like make our own
implementation of a network even like
like a like something that maybe isn't
like in memory only or like saves
everything before it sends it to the
network like congratulations you
invented TCP dump great job or something
that drops 15% of your traffic or
mangles your message in semantically
interesting ways or has like huge
latency but is like really unpredictable
or response to all your messages with
the ping flood or like it does any one
of the horrible things that happen to
machines on networks all the time but in
a way that you can control an assign and
do predictably so like this is so so so
valuable for testing we get the question
a lot like how do you debug a unit
kernel and pretty much that's how you do
bugga unit girl so there's there's
implications for this explicitness in
things besides the network as well so
like we we passed a random number
generator so we can pass like whatever
random number generator we want
including like constant for which is
useful for which is again useful for
testing and also are useful for
debugging when you're if you want to
like remove some of the intentional
stochastic miss from the environment
this is a really useful thing to be able
to do and same goes for clocks
especially in networks singh goes for
clocks it's really really really nice to
be able to pass something a fast clock
or a slow clock or a clock that
sometimes goes back in time and messes
everything up this is a this is a really
fantastic way to find bugs in like your
application code and like all your other
code and like all of everybody's code
ever I recommend it highly so I wanted
to give you a quick look this is just
what that looks like it looks exactly
like the it looks exactly like the
stacks that we were building before we
just put some different stuff in there
so this is this particular one is Mirage
IV net off' which is a virtual network
interface this is a like I shared
back-end so we can plug multiple
multiple virtual network interfaces into
this same bridge and then they can talk
to each other over a lossy link or a
link that only sends cat pictures or
whatever one of which is is this lossing
that if and then we just build our stuff
on top of it it's normal or we
substitute in some fast clocks because
we're trying to do some do some
debugging on our arm on aging out of our
ARP cache so we want to make time go
10,000,000 times faster so we don't have
to wait on Travis for five minutes and
we can combine this with property based
testings to see like really interesting
things like for example whether putting
two of our nodes on these velocity links
together it means that for some reason
we do something wrong in our TCP state
machine so um I have another I have
another neat thing from the neat things
grab-bag that I wanted to talk about so
I I kind of tried to skate by it as
quickly as I could but it's probably
fairly clear that a lot of the
interfaces that I'm talking about for
specific for specific implementations of
these network layers or maybe maybe I
did pull too fast and it wasn't very
clear but a lot of these interfaces are
side affecting and that means that we
have that means that we have data
structures that we can't really make
guarantees on the past of and we don't
necessarily have good ways of imagining
what's going on with them in terms of
like their current state in their past
state and inputs we just sort of lose
the ability to reason nicely about that
and then in in the situation where you
really genuinely do have to have
multiple control paths into something in
order to update it this is pretty hard
to deal with so I'm sorry I'm sorry to
tell you more about our I told you you'd
be happier if you didn't know but I'm
gonna tell you a little bit more about
our penny way and I'm just gonna
apologize ahead of time but I have to
forward a few slides first sorry I have
to get my focus in the right place
we're a computer so hard okay so I'll
just tell you about it so um so this is
a way of mapping it's a way of mapping
IP addresses to link layer addresses and
it also has an expiration time attached
to it
the intention is that you have you have
a whole bunch of nodes that are joining
a network they don't necessarily know
what their IP addresses are but they
have a burned in link layer address that
they always know and so you have to have
some way for these machines to discover
what each other's numbers are which
means that the machines have to know
what their numbers are and they have to
be able to tell the other machines on
the network
that's what ARP is basically imagine it
as just a key value store with an
expiration date attached which is a
super super common structure in these
like really small bits of state that we
see in the network stack but um there's
there's three possible things that you
can imagine happening in terms of
threads in ARP so you might be
responding to an incoming message that
says like hey bro my name is 192.168.0
MAC address queue let's be buds and
you're our cache goes oh yeah okay I
totally want to be buds this is gonna be
great or you might have an incoming
request from something farther up the
stack that says I really need to send a
message to one ninety two dot one sixty
eight dot 3.50 do you know where that is
and the are precious I got this it's
fine and then you also have the
influence of time on the cache where you
had a met you knew where someone lived
but they've gone away and this
information is gone and you just you
have to let go of it and you have to
move on with your life needing to do all
three of those things at once is a bit
difficult so um it's useful to have
ridiculously powerful distributed data
stores that you can use to do that
Erman is a library for four basically
for persistent storage you can do
snapshotting branching and reverting in
it you can basically imagine it as an
interface to get but for your datastore
and you can like the really nice thing
about it is that you can deal with the
stuff that you're putting in the data
in a type of were--we which has the
implication that you can write custom
merge functions that know what your
types are so when you update stuff in
ermine you do it in this kind of like
traditional gateway you clone you edit
you up you try to merge back but you
don't get this because Hermann knows the
types of norman is smarter than this
than this merge algorithm and it knows
for example that if you have that if you
have two changes that are not mutually
exclusive you should be able to merge
them or you can tell it that so for
example in the case of ARP I don't have
the slide but in the case of ARP we have
the we have the very useful property
that the only way that we ever remove a
node is if it's expired and we have a
date for expiry for it so we can write a
really simple merge function that says
always prefer something to nothing and
always prefer something with a later
date to an earlier date which means that
we can trivially put all of this
information into Ehrman and then get it
basically get a get trace of our ARP
cache and the other nice thing about it
is that it provides a whole lot of
backends so you can like run it in
memory and it's not ridiculously slow
and then in testing you can just flip
this basically you can flip what module
you call it with and suddenly it's on
disk and you can see persisting in
memory all of the changes that it's made
this is a really useful thing for
managing the situation where you of
necessity have mutable state and you
don't want to and you're trying to
figure out how you can live in this
awful world that you and everyone else
around you have created for you that's
that's all I've got which is good
because I'm almost out of time but I
would appreciate any questions or
statements that you have thank you for
your